tragedy in berlin this the scene after a
car plowed into people in a main
shopping area
too graphic to fully show
among those hit pupils on a school trip
actor john barrowman was shopping in the
street at the time
we walked over we looked at it
we didn't really think anything of we
thought it was a bad accident um and the
people were kind of scurrying around and
uh
there didn't seem to be any panic
because foot i don't think these people
at this
part of the incident didn't know that
someone was
had been killed up the street so we came
out of the store here and walked across
the street and that's where we saw the
car
go had gone into the uh the building
through the glass window and it also
barreled through
like the cafe
area this is where the car finally came
to stop
a city official said inside officers
found placards relating to turkey
accident or attack so far police aren't
confirming around about 10 30 a man
drove with his car into a
group of person
he injured more than 12
four of them seriously
and one person is dead after
that he
got arrested by
by some people some
witnesses
and then police officer arrested him too
the 29 year old behind the wheel was a
german armenian jewel national he's
still being questioned
this is a popular shopping street in
berlin and we understand the car was
coming in this direction when it hit
people but then continued traveling for
another 200 meters before crashing to a
stop
adding to today's trauma the memory of
2016 when a terrorist plowed down
shoppers at a christmas market
the site of that attack just minutes
from today's crash
so once again this city is searching for
answers
trying to make sense of this latest
heartbreak siobhan robbins sky news
berlin